plot the following numbers on the number
line so the first number we have here is
5 and so 5 is 5 to the right of 0 5 is
right over there that's our 5 then we
get 1/3 1/3 so 1/3 is between 0 & 1 and
we can actually split this into thirds
so that would be 1/3 2/3 and then 3/3
which is 1 so 1/3 is going to sit right
over there it's 1/3 of the way from 0 to
1 that's 1/3 let me write that that's
1/3 right over there then we have
negative 1.2 I'll do that in this blue
color negative 1 point 2 so negative 1
is right over here this is more negative
than negative 1 it's negative 1 point 2
it's negative 1 and then another point 2
so it's going to be right over here so
this is negative 1 point negative 1
point 2 0 is pretty straightforward zero
is right over there it's in even labeled
for us at 0 5 was labeled for us too at
5 then we have negative 2 and 1/4 so
let's go to negative 2 negative 2 is
here and it's going to be it's more
negative than negative 2 its negative 2
and then another negative 1/4 so it's
negative 2 and then we go 1/4 of the way
to negative 3 so negative 2 and 1/4 is
going to be right over here so negative
2 and 1/4 and then finally we have 4.1
4.1 so 4 is right over here
point 1 is another tenth greater than 4
another tenth on the way to 5 so 4 and
1/10 is going to be right over here 4.1
4.1 and we are done